it's fair to say that final Mouse is one
of the most clouted peripheral
manufacturers in the world the ninja air
58 final Mouse literally it's like 58
grams this thing is like the lightest
Mouse in the market final Mouse don't
just produce gaming mice they make
exclusive works of art that only a
handful of Gamers can even dream of
getting their hands on I know this is
going to kind of like a kind of sound
like a douchebag thing to say but these
are real diamonds and this past year
final Mouse decided to partner with not
only the face of Sentinels valorant
roster but one of the most peripheral
obsessed aim gods in the world can I
break this well I'll get outside later
the tens Starlight Pro was one of the
most hyped Mouse releases of all time
the question is is it any good
[Music]
okay so before we start talking about
whether or not we heck and loved this
mouse I wanted to let you all know that
we have new merch head over to
shop.thescore.com and check out all of
our super cool Esports designs all right
so where the hell did final Mouse come
from well technically they've been
manufacturing mice since 2014. but it
wasn't until the following year that
they really began to gain recognition
their Ergo and tournament pro products
slowly but surely helped them get their
foot in the door and then they famously
partnered up with Scream giving us this
beauty right here they talk about my
went UPS not everyone bought into the
hype though and some consumers found
themselves struggling with some annoying
hardware and firmware issues
so how the hell did final Mouse go from
that to partnering up with valorant
royalty well before I tell the story of
the subject of this video the hallowed
tens Starlight I must first discuss
fortnite you see back in the summer of
2017 fortnite took the gaming World by
storm battle royale's were already
dominating viewership on Twitch but
fortnite was different it was a new take
on the genre where you didn't just rely
on looting and shooting you could also
Farm resources and build structures to
help protect yourself and give you an
edge over your opponent
let's go and as The Meta developed and
players became increasingly cracked at
building more and more kitties
started buying and building gaming PCs
and entering The Fray
s oh it's not metal now
that was dirty but all of these fortnite
obsessed Zoomers looked up to one
blue-haired Boomer in particular and
when he set out to find a lighter Mouse
to help with his high-level build
battles the ninja air 58 final mouse was
born I originally relied heavily on a
lot of like side buttons on the mouse
but I started using this for like a week
I broke down I had a bad day I was like
I'm going back I'm gonna go back to my
old mouse and I literally immedi I
plugged in for one game got destroyed
because it was too heavy took it threw
it out put it back in and I've never
looked back I literally use this every
single day to game man this is what I
destroy my enemies with them fortnite
man super essential back then ninja was
the king of twitch he had more than a
hundred thousand subscribers he was
playing fortnite with celebrities and
the sponsorships were flooding in ninja
was a household name unlike final mouse
sure final Mouse did make that scream
mouse back in 2016 but the mouse Market
was changing more and more manufacturers
were making strides in constructing the
lightest mice possible so this ninja
branded 58 gram Dome clicker definitely
turned some heads having a light Mouse
in fortnite was like pretty pretty good
because I I was using a big ass ec2a at
the start of uh fortnite like my aim was
really good but you need like speed and
like it just looks really cool while
also being very light and having a light
Mouse is just like it feels like you're
moving almost nothing as more and more
kids began cranking 90s and bming their
opponents in build battles they realized
that speed speed was King and that by
using a lighter Mouse they could be
faster than everyone else on the server
but final Mouse weren't just getting
attention because of the weight of their
mice their business model was unlike
anything we've ever seen from any of the
major peripheral manufacturers instead
of Simply putting their products up for
sale and hoping for the best final Mouse
decided that they were gonna do
exclusive drops with unique colorways
similar to what you'd expect when vying
for limited edition sneakers or
streetwear and just like with Yeezys or
off-white Nikes final Mouse products
eventually became a scalper's dream
boasting insane price tags on a bunch of
resale sites of course this was
frustrating to those who couldn't get
their hands on them before the scalpers
did but for final Mouse The Limited
releases all but guaranteed that every
time they came out with a new product it
would sell out within a couple of hours
sometimes even minutes oh it's sold out
that is oh that's sick that's sickening
okay can I get a small this trend
continued with each of their new
products final Mouse would release a
newer lighter Mouse and it would sell
out everyone wanted to be a part of the
exclusive drop and that's the thing of
final Mouse too is that they're so
limited that you feel like you need to
get it or you just won't ever have it
final Mouse we're killing it and this
meant that they could go toe-to-toe with
some of the more established peripheral
manufacturers like Razer and Logitech
and zowie but as hyped up as their
products were
they were far from perfect I was just
disappointed with how they executed you
know the like the mouse tension with the
clicks and all that um I feel like it
felt too heavy
um I didn't like that at the price point
they were using Omron still
uh it did have a little bit of quality
control issues like a couple of scroll
Wheels came crooked and all that stuff
um so as far as that goes I was a little
disappointed with their first launch and
yet in spite of their QA issues final
Mouse still had clout they organized
exclusive limited edition releases and
some of the biggest Esports
Personalities in the world continued to
rock their products but this past year
final Mouse secured arguably their
biggest collaboration yet no no you're
in my room the tens Starlight Pro was
easily among the most hyped Mouse
releases ever final Mouse had already
collaborated with big names before but
this time was different this time it was
tens they announced the tens Mouse I was
like all right I mean tents hey
tens I was like oh I'm gonna play
like tens aside from being one of the
biggest faces in all of valorent
Sentinels is cracked aimed demon is
known for repeatedly changing up his
settings and peripherals if a new mouse
drops then chances are tens will at the
very least try it sometimes even mid
tournament because he's just built like
that so as you can imagine tenza's name
alone had people in the FPS Community
foaming at the mouth and to no one's
surprise all 40 000 units of this new
magnesium alloy Starlight sold out
within a couple of hours now I know a
lot of you are probably wondering why it
is that 40 000 people forked over 189 US
dollars for this weird metal Mouse and
if it was worth it well luckily for you
our boy Nile actually managed to get his
hands on one and here's what he had to
say and now the guy who actually knows
what he's talking about all right don't
worry guys Colton will be back in the
next one I'm just subbing in because I'm
the guy who actually tested out the
mouse so I gotta start by letting you
know that my primary mess for the past
few years has been the g-pro and more
recently the super light I'm not huge on
Ergo mice and I really enjoy the weight
and shape of the super light so it's
been my main Mouse for a while now but
when I saw that final mouse was
releasing a new Starlight Pro in
collaboration with tens I figured it is
finally time to try one out I purchased
the medium size which is honestly pretty
close to the size and shape of the G Pro
the hump on the final Mouse is only
slightly flatter but otherwise they're
pretty similar I know that some people
were expecting the tens version to have
a bit more of a hump but it's actually
the same shape as the Phantom the mouse
itself looks sleek you can make out the
word Starlight engraved on the edge of
the right Mouse button and on the bottom
of the mouse you can check to see which
number you received out of the 40 000
that were produced most one and two on
the tens most feel good they're light
and fairly quiet and luckily I didn't
get a crooked scroll wheel but most
importantly here's how the clicks sound
before I get into my review I have to
mention that I tested it out with the
stock skates on an artisan hen Pad but
to start I want to talk about the weight
because it was a bit of a shock I knew
that going from a 63 gram Mouse to one
that's roughly 47 grams was going to
take some getting used to but this thing
is insanely light for me I consistently
found myself over aiming which I
expected so I began compensating for the
lack of weight by lowering my scents
first I went down from 0.25 on 800 DPI
to 0.2 and honestly this still felt way
too fast for me so then I went and
lowered it to 0.175 thought that that
was too slow and eventually found my way
to 0.187 which is what I've settled on
for the past couple of weeks I've been
able to find more equilibrium and I'm
slowly getting used to the weight of the
mouse but I'll just have to wait and see
if I can find that same consistency that
I had with the super light more recently
I decided to try out the included
Infinity skins it ships with three
options 1.2 millimeter two millimeter
and 2.5 millimeter which are basically
just grips for each side of the mouse I
tried the two millimeter ones but but
after I played for a while the right
side of my hand started to feel
uncomfortable so I removed the infinity
skin from that side and decided to just
rock one on the left side the infinity
skin feels nice and adds a bit of weight
to the mouse but not enough to make a
noticeable difference overall I think
it's a great Mouse historically final
Mouse products have been the go-to for
cracked assumers but I think that most
people can enjoy this mouse if they can
get used to the weight unfortunately I'm
not one of those people I just can't get
used to it I'm not a zowie Stan who
enjoys holding a brick in my hand either
but this thing is just way too
lightweight for me and that was the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about and now that the mouse has been
out for a couple of months we've heard
other members of the Esports Community
give their opinion as well yeah I mean I
had an air 58 back then and this mouse
kind of just like it reminds me of that
shape and it's just Wireless I mean it's
good I like it a lot
more backside
I would have never done that without the
tens of us bro I heck and love tents bro
I loved him I said it the 10 Starlight
Pro is absolutely a very high quality
product it might be made for a select
group of Gamers but you can tell that
final Mouse have listened to the
community with this one they've built a
mouse that even some of their most vocal
critics can respect so they started
listening to community feedback and all
that
um and I think when I got my tense I can
say that the quality is actually there
now for like 180 I think the quality is
really there when it comes to gaming
peripherals it's all a matter of
preference right now for instance I've
actually gone back to rocking my za11b
since I found that the 72 gram C was
actually just a tad to light for me that
said if what you're looking for is an
extremely lightweight high quality
gaming mouse than the 10 Starlight Pro
might just be for you if you can get
your hands on one
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock